hopefully you all read the descriptions
yes
good to you now they're on the same page
i just have one more request of you as
we talk about this
i want you to put in your mind that
we're not going to talk about your skill
set i'm sure each one of you are in the
top 10
because you're here and you cared enough
to increase your education so this is
not going to be about how much or little
you know about a specific framework or
architectural style this is going to be
a little bit of a talk about
how
you can be in the very front of
someone's mind when they say hey do you
know any net developers
do you know anybody who knows
f sharp
do you know anybody who's really good at
leading a team we're looking for someone
it needs to be
right frame of mind
and luckily for all of us this is a
scientific process
so
as a developer i figured some of this
out and i wanted to share it with you
so if you've never met me before let me
introduce myself my name is heather
downing i do lots of things and lots of
stuff
see look i have lots of words see i do
all things
unfortunately for the human brain we
especially over the years have gotten to
the point where we need snapshots of
information or you just lose us
sometimes when has anybody write a
resume that is five pages long
yeah
when did you check out
after the which part did you check out
him
page one halfway down
did you even read the last one it was i
was notorious for this because i was so
insecure that i'm like i have to put
everything you know once i i fixed my
grandma's computer you know this one
time and i would put anything i've done
with the community on the last page so
nobody ever looked at that they never
got to that page right
and i was called out for exactly what it
was which was information overload now
this isn't too bad for you all because
you're used to reading docs that are
egregiously long right so you probably
have all read this by now right or did
you stop at the first paragraph second
or third
probably the first
because you're not really interested in
all the rest
what you should think about doing are
keywords
so when somebody is describing you or
thinks about you they associate you with
one word or two words like
that i'm really interested in innovative
tech so think of innovation i'm always
the one doing something that is not
proved out yet
okay
so that should be the word is associated
with me another one i was told is
enterprise because yes i like making
money and i like fixing problems in the
world's infrastructure so that puts me
in this camp
consumer facing this often comes up
because they know that i've worked for
disneyland as a jungle crew skipper and
i also used to work for marion
international for like a decade
so i know a whole lot about how to be in
front of people and they remember that i
was a latecomer to tech right about the
age of 26
and have been in it ever since
and
that i'm a speaker
in the circles i'm in that's usually one
of the first things that they say but if
you didn't know i was a speaker and you
were in other aspects of my life that
might be what you know isn't this a lot
more digestible than all the words i
just put up before
that's pretty simple right
i don't like repeating things but often
for being a group of people that
absolutely despise writing code twice
have you looked at your resumes
and sometimes when you get to the point
where you don't even have a resume
guilty as charge linkedin is wonderful
for this that you can
export a profile as a resume it's an
excellent option but unfortunately it
follows the same problems that i just
discussed before however much you put on
there and repeat of structures and
unstructured sentences that all gets
printed up
so just think about really to the point
key ways that you can be memorable
this is the question of the decade isn't
it what is it that you want
right now i would say i'm in a very
privileged company that i know some
people who have truly changed the face
of technology as we know it and so the
problems that they have are different
than the problems of
my down the street neighbor who started
tech about five years ago is in that
wonderful mid-level place anybody a
mid-level developer here anybody a few
of you it gets better
hang in there
and unfortunately they were not
introduced to the people i were that's
introduced to the people that i was so
what they want is just how to be how to
have less pain
at their job and sometimes that's to
leave that job
and
right now there are lots of jobs but you
may take the pain with you so you have
to ask yourself what is it that you're
that you're really trying to solve by
coming to this talk or are you just
interested in what i have to say
research confirms that there's a real
disconnect between your performance and
your job outcomes so to get into that
we'll dive into how humans perceive each
other
so you i know you all join this because
you want to become rich and famous
developers but that's gonna be like five
percent of the time and the other 95
will be talking about human psychology
because science
all right
you can drive your perception how people
perceive you at your workplace
uh in your community and
basically how the industry
views you
we'll be exploring both sides of this
so we don't want to stick out for the
wrong reasons we don't like being the
odd one out i felt this many many many
many times as somebody who got into tech
later i felt like everybody was a lot
younger than me
and we were right about the same level
so i just felt like i was making jokes
about nirvana and they had no idea who
nirvana was you know that was a problem
i felt like was a problem but it turned
out that
that was the first way their brain
recalled is that i love all sorts of
different cool and weird music was the
first thing that they remembered about
me and then it turned into something
else later on the line
so you can look at it like you stick out
like a black sheep or a sore thumb
or you can take control of that
narrative
take control of it like it or not you
have a brand
and you can decide if you want to craft
it into something that's helpful for you
so um let me say you think somebody who
has an excellent brand
it could be the clothes you wear it
could be a fun hat it could be the way
you talk especially if you're in a
foreign country and they can tell that
you're not from there that's often one
way
but you have one
ask people how they would describe you
to others and it
make sure that it's honest and it's not
just oh yeah these this brilliant
developer i know that knows all the
things now how do you remember me oh i
remember that you're always going to
concerts here or i remember you're
always working on this one startup idea
where i remember that you have 12
children whatever it is whether you like
it or not people have a little bit of a
shortcut
to jogging in their memory about you so
craft it use it to your benefit
embrace sticking out for good reasons
which brings me to why others get
promoted before you
[Music]
are already going down on that energy
already
here's the truth are you ready for the
truth if you're too busy keeping your
head down nose to the grindstone it's
really hard to see you without an ally
or an advocate speaking up for what the
heck you've been doing
whether it's for your own projects or
for the company it doesn't matter if
people will never talk to you and never
see you you don't exist it's great that
they have a product that exists but you
don't they don't register and this is
not their fault they're not trying to
ignore you oftentimes you're probably
one of many people and we can only keep
track of so many i'm trying to remember
the exact number of how many people your
brain can keep track of but it's not a
lot
so you have to constantly be reminding
and that sounds so egotistical doesn't
it i always felt like i was just
struggling all the time because i was
constantly doing all the innovative tech
that nobody knew about so nobody could
help me and i was like i don't really
know why this is broken why it doesn't
work and i was i felt like i was just
trying to swim so i didn't have time to
think about whether or not people saw i
was doing anything
how much the world's changed just in the
past four to five years when it comes to
being visible
so part of managing yourself
and your career trajectory is making it
easier for people and opportunities to
find you that's it that's all you're
doing you're just making it easier for
the right things to come to you some
people call that manifesting i just call
that logic
i mean if nobody knows you have a skill
no one's going to come to you
with how to fix that problem
so if you get coy or bashful about
anything you've accomplished even if
it's small
that doesn't really help you in fact it
probably hurts you
because let's say
i don't know we have a big recession and
everybody tightens their belts and they
let people go you don't want to be a
faceless developer that nobody really
knows what they did here you want to
make sure that you are known for what
you bring to the table and more
importantly for what you desire to bring
to the table
because that means you have a future
maybe at that company or just in your
career in general
so why does the idiot get all the
responsibility
you're only laughing because you have
experienced this before
right
guess what you know that idiot you saw
that was promoted that's because it was
self-promoting shamelessly loudly and
often
prove me wrong
and you should also
be promoting yourself loudly and often
and that is really hard i was not raised
that way
and so that's very difficult for me i
was waiting for somebody else to speak
for me
why would you give other humans that
much control over how much money you
make and what you get to do in this life
come on
this is something you can take control
of there is a much more refined way of
doing it than the idiot that did it
right you don't need to lose
self-respect in the process by saying
i'm amazing
that's not the goal here just remember
the first half of your job is to
actually do it you know
please code please help your team and
actually do that
but then you got the other half of your
job that nobody tells you in school or
boot camp
which is
how to communicate
what it is that you're doing
i feel like
all of these
science degrees need to come with a
hefty amount of human skill training
because
that
the breakdowns we often have in tech are
not technically related it's human
related has to do with where the human
failed usually in communicating
something was wrong or not right
sent does not mean received
right i could send you all the messages
that doesn't mean that they got it so
sometimes half of your job is to reword
and check on people to make sure that
they understand
where you're coming from or what it is
you've done
if you do it and i don't hear about it
how do i know what's going on here
you're sitting in your own little world
thinking i'm never recognized stay up
really late doing this i work on a
saturday don't do that work on a
saturday
getting all this and i get no
recognition and i get like this tiny
little raise it's like five dollars more
oh
and then you get resentful
and here this other person
that was your leader or somebody who had
at least the ability to influence
whether or not you made more money or
got more responsibility isn't even
thinking bad things about you at all
they're just juggling all the other 3
000 things they have to do it probably
isn't that personal or they only thought
about it for five minutes because you
didn't make it easy to advocate for you
you didn't make it easy to see what
you've done please make it easy
if you have to ask for more one-on-one
times and it's not just with a person
who has control over your career it is
about the rest of your team
there's something more new that i
noticed the companies i worked with that
were starting to be done so please let
me know if you're also experiencing this
you get kind of like a rate your boss
and your co-workers thing like tell me
do you like working these people do you
not like working with them your opinion
matters you know
do you get anybody else get those kinds
of things
it's a little weird because you feel
like when you are fighting the good
fight together trying to ship something
you're supposed to suddenly be brutally
honest about how well they could
be more on time for standups and they
could be you know
it feels
disingenuous
because that is how a company forces
people to start talking about it but
that seems really fake
so if things are already naturally or
naturally checking on each other and
seeing how you need to communicate
differently to each person which feels
exhausting but it really isn't bad once
you set it in place
then you won't ever have those problems
you won't be asked those kinds of silly
things because it will be very obvious
where the team's going where the
individual's going
so all that lovely amount of speaking
that i did comes down to this do things
and tell people
that's your slide
thank you for coming my ted talk no
we just we just miss out when we wrongly
assume that other people will know about
our great work without having to tell
them
but so remember human the human machine
is fallible so please help
so part of the way that i discovered was
super helpful
to
have good opportunities come my way is
to do something anyway even if it wasn't
in my company like i was really
interested for a while in voice a lot of
work with like alexa and google
assistant i was interested in that stuff
and i was definitely working for an
insurance company so like it was not
really like an alignment there but i
still wanted to do it anyway just
because i was interested so i took the
time on my own
to just kind of
discover a little bit about it and
because i was chatting with somebody
else that was like hey you know you
should
present that at a user group i'm like uh
no because i do not work for google or
amazon and i do not want to say
the wrong thing about this process
they're like why don't you just
why don't you just be the alice in the
wonderland just explain to us what
you've seen so far you don't have to
have all of the end result you can just
say this is what i learned so far that i
think is pretty cool and i felt like all
right that's cool
fast forward i was working into another
working in another company in a pretty
hardcore dev team and
because my manager was searching for how
to
integrate something
with a voice api he stumbled upon a post
i made on my own blog and came to me
saying hey we're actually thinking about
doing this for a whole nother team
another project
do you want to work on this and i'm like
what yes i would love to do that and
it's it and remember i didn't have to
advocate inside of my company they just
stumbled upon the fact that i was doing
this and then it just kind of naturally
progressed
because sometimes you you need to not
ask permission to show what you're
capable of you just need to put it out
there
and trust that the right people and
opportunities will find you as long as
you
put it out there right
because the reality is that working hard
and doing a good job is insufficient
for a career trajectory
i'm sorry
because there's just a lot there's a lot
of us
and it doesn't mean that we don't need
more we totally do
but if you want to not be stuck
perpetually where you are
you have to
make sure that you are seen and if you
can't get seen inside of your company
make sure you're seen out of it but i
would argue you should go outside
regardless because
leading by example externally can
demonstrate that ability
like what i just went through
just make it easy for people to find and
endorse you that's it
which is another reason why you should
network
thank you for coming to a place where
you can network i appreciate that having
a large and valuable network is a
fantastic asset for advancing your
career and your life
in general
but it doesn't mean what you think it
means
i really hated that work because i i
watched a lot of like uh television
shows about networking and how
disingenuous it felt like hi i need to
use you in the future for some reason so
um here's my card
and it felt really weird i had gone to
several business networking events and
it was overwhelming i felt like i was in
a car sales
you know convention it was i didn't like
it i just wanted to kind of work and do
my own thing but that's because i'm a
natural introvert and i've had to
practice
doing this in front of you all like i
don't naturally want to do that i tend
to stay in my own corner with my own
people that i know
so when most programmers ask me about
networking what they're really asking
about is how they can use people to
advance in their career okay
and i'm not about that at all
so
in my personal philosophy
and the one i firmly believe
is to figure out how you can give as
many other people as possible what they
want or even better what they need
um so i'm always checking our friends
like hey how are you doing for this how
are you doing for that someone knew i'm
like great what it is you're interested
in so that if i know somebody
that would be good to connect with you i
can
the current job that i have
it was because someone knew me like oh
we knew that we needed somebody who knew
the.net community and was not afraid to
get up on stage i said okay here i am
let's do it but that's because they knew
me
so if you think about it in the reverse
it becomes much more selfless
you need to put out and ask what other
people are needing
[Music]
because there's also a wrong way to
network right
usually people only network when they
need a new job
okay that's the only time they do it
because they have to right that's they
have to do it hey you know i'm
interested i'm open you can pretend like
you're not looking at all you're like oh
you know i'm just casually maybe
in the future someday
and they kind of drop that big hit like
a shoe right
but that is the absolute worst time and
the wrong way to build your network
people won't trust you
building a network takes a lot of time
trying to rush that process and do it
quickly
reeks of desperation so please don't do
that
um a recruiter
by
uh
i don't know comparison would be
something i would call a temporary
relationship okay
they
it's really there to further their
monetary gain and your monetary gain
right for both parties so you like hey
you and i both want to make money let's
find you a job
that's not networking that's somebody
whose job it is to literally place you
so they make money
and they're often not in your best
interest because they just want to place
somebody so they get that okay
so you have to advocate the right way it
doesn't mean you can't work with
recruiters i have lots of people i can
refer you to if you want to know which
recruiters are great
but
you might find you won't even need
recruiters in the future because you're
starting to network with the right
people anyway
so remember recruiters will work with
you regardless of your networking skills
and that is not an accurate
representation of what networking is
fair
so let's talk about the right way
just like romantic relationships real
business and professional relationships
cannot be rushed because you spend just
as much time with your co-workers as you
do your family
so imagine if you met a person
that you'd like to pursue a romantic
relationship with and on the first date
you ask them to marry you
i mean i guess
some movies have been made about that
right
that probably wouldn't go over too well
though because many software developers
want to approach networking in exactly
that manner
you know instead think about the long
game
think about networking as planting a
large number of little seeds that you're
going to water and nurture until they
grow into large plants that eventually
will produce fruit for you but it's
going to be a long game right
you can't rush that process and you have
to be very deliberate about that you
can't just hang out and hope it goes
well you need to be deliberate about
saying i'm somebody who's interested in
this and my future
it also remember makes it easier for
others to help you because they know you
have a concrete idea of the kinds of
places you want to go in life
so remember the best way to plan to
nurture the seeds of networking is to
give first and ask others first
and then you will generate some good
will and that will naturally occur
notice i'm not telling you to manipulate
anybody this is just offer
and that will generate goodwill
network in person hooray we get to do
this again
right so where do you actually go to do
that the short answer is everywhere and
today you've chosen ndc london well done
you should always be networking if you
can the easiest and best things to do in
this case is to find a group of people
who are interested in what you're
interested in
if you don't have any conferences near
you please go to like meetup.com is a
good one i'm sure that you'll hear
through the grapevine from others other
places to go
and even though
software development conferences can be
a little expensive
there are also great places to meet new
people and pick up some training as well
if you do a workshop
sometimes you'll work at a good company
that will pay for you to go which is
always good
because when you're there remember to
walk around and talk to people attend
different sessions and talk to the
speakers we don't bite we will talk to
you promise
go up to the speaker of a session that
you watched afterwards or later when you
see them and thank them for their
presentation and give them lots of good
compliments because you know that they
are really stressed out when they
present for you
not i don't really say that for me i'm
totally fine but i do know speakers
who've slaved away for weeks on their
presentation and no one ever talks to
them after and that's hard right so
remember that giving first to say hey i
really appreciated this thank you and
tell them why if you retained any of
their session
and consider what is my favorite part of
a conference which is the hallway track
so besides eating a delicious lunch did
anybody actually talk to somebody
they've never met before
between sessions anybody yeah
okay so about half of you that's good
the other half of you have an assignment
it doesn't even matter if you know what
they do just say hi what you know i'm
excited to be here um what do you do why
are you here that's a good question why
are you here
that's that's your icebreaker for today
um also go to any after parties or
genders that they have that's often when
people will really get and dig into how
life is truly going
you know the projected path of
technology and things are truly
passionate about come out usually after
the conference during the dinner or
beverages later that's when i find the
really
great deep deeply felt conversations are
had
i've heard it said that your network is
your net worth
okay
i guess i found that statement to be
true more often than most people would
imagine
and
that also kind of leads me into how
false it can feel if you know somebody
that knows you then suddenly you have a
lot more doors and you can be envious of
those people who have those doors or you
can go get some doors
right how do you get doors
this is everybody's favorite subject
um regardless of what you personally
believe about social media
you you need to use it so that you're
not out of sight and out of mind
and you can schedule things i promise as
long as you keep one thing in mind it
shouldn't be a crazy terrible experience
and that is to be your honest self but
be kind about it
so when it comes to creating an
authentic personal brand and i hate
talking like a marketer but guess what
it's real
that means you have to share the good
the bad and the real with your followers
aspirational is great but being
relatable is actually what creates
connections for example if you were to
scroll back on my twitter a few weeks i
was like oh this is great bitlocker
locked me out of my
entire drive i guess i get to erase and
start over again because somebody lost
the password and
you know here we are
and uh that started a whole conversation
yes i should know better yes i shouldn't
have had that but i have had that
computer for like seven years and forgot
completely about any of this best
practice stuff when i set it up right
so but it's okay because that pain is
like oh i feel that pain too i
understand
so you can definitely be a little bit
more genuine with your content but also
still help i think it's important to
throw in that i'm very human see
look
with hey here's something i learned that
i think is cool so that you don't have
to feel that pain
that's usually the best mix i've studied
a lot of people before i worked where i
work now i worked for a worldwide
marketing company as our innovation
engineer and let me tell you i
subconsciously picked up a whole lot
about what humans like online as like a
good persona in the united states there
is a brand
of hamburgers called wendy's has anybody
ever heard of this go look at their
twitter
it's hilarious and they somehow have
managed to strike the balance between
kind of
teasing other brands like mcdonald's or
something
online and they were almost the original
creator of how to roast people you know
but do it in a way that people weren't
angry about it because it wasn't mean
spirit it was just fun
and i got to sit next to the person who
helped create their persona when i was
at my job and i was like how do you
think about these things he's like
because the truth is so hilarious
he says you know we can just put it in a
creative way but the truth is really
funny the truth is as a net developer i
am so overwhelmed the amount of versions
we've had in the past three years i'm
like whoa that's just a lot so i can
talk about how excited i am about the
new thing while also acknowledging that
too many versions also what is naming
happening at all i don't know we've
decided it's going to be this now we're
not going to go in any sort of order
it's just going to be this now and i can
laugh about that because it's true and
that will probably get a lot of
engagement online your goal is not to
become a marketer for yourself your goal
is to just put little thoughts out there
so that you're in front of people more
often and if you don't like thinking
about that and checking in on social
media on a daily basis which i totally
understand then schedule it please but
when you schedule something to post post
with purpose
avoid filler content uh because it
doesn't connect with people and people
can smell that out especially you all
because you're all very smart
i used to stress out if i didn't share
something with my online audience every
day or i would search for something
anything that might keep the engagement
going and share that link right with no
commentary here here's more stuff see
look notice me you know that's what it
felt like
but
that wasn't giving my audience the best
view of me and i didn't come across as
authentic or genuine which if you ever
meet me i'm pretty down to earth so
i didn't want it to feel like a
different person i wanted to feel like
me
and it came off as filler don't do
filler content don't do filler content
okay
so now before you post online ask
yourself
what purpose does this
message serve regardless of where you
post it
and how am i connecting to my audience
and does this contribute to my personal
brand remember you have a personal brand
whether you like it or not
your personal brand means how others see
you how do you want others to see you
how do you want to present
a good way to do that is to speak like a
human being
we are notorious for jargon we're not as
bad as
as some academics though there is
definitely some academics out there but
we are notorious for jargon i didn't
even know what kubernetes was for the
first two years was out i didn't care
because i'm like i don't know what that
is whatever and then i had it explained
to me like a human being i was like oh
that's pretty good idea
that sounds good my advice for
developing your tone of voice is simple
just don't overthink it
and speak to your audience like you
would a friend
informal and kind of upbeat if you can
unless you're just angry at life
maybe you should not be posting online
just because the question is what value
are you bringing to the audience if all
you're doing is complaining
um
like i'm laughing a little bit about the
version joke for net but i also deeply
appreciate how much more stable.net is
than the other things i have tried right
so
i'm just poking a little bit of fun at
it so i don't take it too seriously but
that's different than just always
ranting
okay
if you're gonna say
something is not right
provide a solution or how you would do
it
you never know who might be watching you
tweet could be somebody who actually
would take that advice and does
implement it that's pretty cool
so
[Music]
try to be moderately responsive i'm so
bad at this
um people will comment and i will have
thought that i've read something and
then i thought i would have
responded but i don't
do that with my text too oh yeah i will
respond later never silence it's because
i've looked at it therefore my brain
automatically thinks
of the response but if i don't bring it
to fruition then it's like a check mark
that has gone off in the list in my head
right
so leave things on read until you can
actually get to them
and it should only take you like a
minute to respond if possible
social media has the word
social in it for a reason so in order to
grow your personal brand you need to
nurture a community and respect your
readers the same way you would want to
be respected online
and create conversations answer
questions and ask them that's one of my
favorite things to do is i'm not i don't
know the answer but i can
i can bring it out i can ask a question
and then all of a sudden all these
people will have an idea about what the
answer is
and that also
starts a discussion i'm good at starting
discussions
occasionally i'm good at giving an
opinion but it really is about the
exchange that happens with more than one
person
um
if you're thinking about where to go
that changes for a while it was facebook
that's where all the developers were um
reddit has been around forever um
twitter is obviously where a lot of tech
people are but i'm finding it isn't just
stack overflow now it's different places
and you can ask others where they get
where they would go to get the latest
information about tutorials or just to
talk to people about the state of tech
and that does change
so you have to kind of just be aware
that it may change i'm having the time
of my life creating a bunch of content
for tick tock right now and it sounds
like you're just going to roll your eyes
but i watched exactly one video from a
developer who did the super cool
shortcut and and they showed it in 10 to
30 seconds and i was like that's amazing
i want to do that kind of stuff because
i can pay attention that long 30 seconds
is good all right let's do that and
you can think of what you will about the
platform but the reason that tick tock
is popular
and youtube shorts are popular is
because we have lost a lot of our
ability to concentrate for long amounts
of time
so you can decide if you're going to
create a youtube video that is two hours
long
or 20 minutes long or maybe two minutes
long and what kind of value you would
put in there
you don't get need to engage every
second of every day just do with a small
amount of consistency so you don't miss
like any engagement opportunities you
know because if you're not online you're
out of sight true story
that doesn't mean that you aren't good
at what you're doing i'm not arguing
that at all but remember you need to be
at the
frontal cortex right you need when
someone said
who is good in desect ops and i'm like
oh this person because i just saw them
at a conference or because i just
watched one of their
videos or i just write a blog post
that's all this is about
so be consistent because if it's too old
and you haven't done things in a long
time
the same thing happens that you just
aren't in front
and remember you think about things
every day just take a little bit of
valley oh that might be good to share
write it down and share it
what i like to do is automate my online
thought stream
that's really helpful so i use something
called hootsuite does anybody else use
hootsuite nobody haha you've all become
much more powerful networkers now
hootsuite is great because while i'm
here at a conference i heard people say
things that made me think of like
something that would be very quotable
like oh
this is you know you should always be
learning or whatever something that is
inspirational but also hey you know the
we are not a
completely mature industry yet like
somebody who's in plumbing or
you know is certified to do stuff we're
still a very young industry and to keep
in mind that we are trying to build
things while the train is on the track
and i thought that was a cool thought so
i wrote that wrote that down i now have
a list of like 10 different things i can
send out
and i schedule them to go out every few
days so that means i don't need to come
up with new things for like three weeks
or two weeks or whatever and that way it
makes you feel
um like you can take
um
advantage of your time
if anybody has experienced like bouts of
total brilliance followed by i don't
want to get out of bed you know those
are good times be like ooh i feel super
really i'm going to write down a bunch
of stuff and at least while i don't feel
like tweeting or doing something it'll
at least be going out on a scheduled
basis right pretty cool
consistency is great visibility is good
but consistency is great because then
you're always brought to the forefront
where we are not perfectly on time
machines so automate that communication
to take that pressure off um this one i
didn't think i'd have to do but uh the
amount of people i've have asked me for
help in the past three weeks alone
means it needs its dead own dedicated
slide and that is please make sure you
have a website that works and is
dedicated to what your works are
i know it feels old-fashioned but please
put everything in a box
to make it easier for them to say don't
make me go through every single social
profile you have in order to find out
information every single github you have
put it all in one place that and then
connect those so that i know where to go
that's all that is it's pretty simple
please do that i can help you talk to me
after you need
um
i believe skills can be taught but
attitude cannot
[Music]
people decide if they like you in the
first five to seven seconds they meet
you because of this thing right here
you really should have met me early in
my tech career i was not a friendly
person i left
hotels in 11 years work in that industry
because i hated people
i did not want to work there i just
wanted to fix problems and stop saying
i'm sorry that you're this is broken
we'll try to get someone to fix it but
not be able to actually fix the problem
it drove me nuts because i wanted to
actually fix problems you know so i got
into tech so i could fix problems
and i didn't really want people to talk
to me
so it was rough i definitely squandered
some excellent opportunities early on
because i didn't put myself in the right
mindset so put yourself in my mindset if
you're not in the right mindset get some
therapy it works
it's awesome because all you're going to
do is stand in the way of all the
amazing things you're capable of and can
accomplish don't you feel better about
yourself now
life isn't fair and that always really
irked me i felt like if i worked really
hard that i would get recognized and i
would go but it turns out i had a
terrible attitude and people just didn't
want to work with me
that's the true story
the day i learned to accept the fact
that as hard as i may try some things
were still out of my control
was difficult
you know i
felt like
i couldn't
overcome some systemic problems that
were in our industry and i couldn't
overcome
certain aspects everything was just
against me that is the wrong way to look
at it even if part of it is true it is
not a fair setup
we are not equal in almost any way
because the way you were born and sorry
who you're born to where you're born all
this stuff will play in to how you
function as an adult
so
just by that nature some people are
going to be better at
executing certain aspects of software
development than others okay
doesn't mean you can't overcome certain
things
but i've discovered that
what i really needed to do is change my
attitude because it wasn't helping
so please if you want to become a runner
don't shoot yourself in the foot
please
so
after i've discovered that i was a mess
and i needed to fix it i started looking
at the developers i actually liked
outside of my company that were visible
online and at a conference right and i
started asking them questions over the
course of five years i put together a
list because remember i like being
scientific like this put together a list
that were habits of well-known
developers
and i'd love to share that
the good news is becoming a super
employee a
well-known developer is not some
rarefied secret at all it's a
combination of skill set and mindset
that you can develop for yourself okay
based on these key habits right the
first one is
to pay attention to what other people
value
super employees are studying the
preferences and goals of their direct
supervisors their their supervisors
supervisors
and their managers supervisors and
everybody on the chain and all the way
up to what the company does at large
they're doing things above and beyond
what other employees are doing because
they're showing interest
they're just interested even if they're
not doing it yet they were showing
interest to the people above them
they're motivated in showing
what they want to learn
and that they want to go
become a top level person right
the result of paying attention
is being able to discern what probably
needs to be done
and take action on it without being
asked
every time i've talked to somebody who's
super respected in the industry it's
always because they said this really
needs to be done and i know the goal is
this overall so i bet you this would
help further that goal
i'm gonna just do it and then show what
i did
and
see if
i can get anybody else on board with
this idea almost every time that's what
it was i can name so many of the
familiar faces in this room that have
done that exact thing
the other thing that they do is they
choose the right place for their talents
it's hard to be a super employee if the
company's needs are very different than
your abilities talents and values isn't
it
a 2015 research report by the cicero
group
found that one of the most important
factors in employees that consistently
produce great work was just recognition
that they were doing good work
and 37 of respondents said that being
recognized by their manager or by the
company was the most important driver in
continually producing great work
so choosing where you work
and where you can be work uh where you
can work where you are valued is very
important but you don't know that you
get like three dates with your employer
and then you get hired right it's a
little weird
you don't get to talk about what you
know what kind of kid you want to raise
or if you even want kids and all these
things you don't get to really deep dive
unless you
come prepared with those questions
where is this company really going like
what do you think about micromanagement
what do you think about these things
asking good questions
ask better questions before you marry
the company you're at
right
they also focus on big picture thinking
these
exceptional performers right they're
able to maintain a dual focus on both
the task in hand as well at how it fits
into that picture
which i always envied
i was really into the minutia i love the
like the little individual pieces coming
together but the why
unfortunately some companies can take
advantage of this and you work on that
minutiae and that becomes interesting to
you and not that you are furthering a
company that is maybe kind of evil
right
i've talked to many developers who's
worked at some of those evil
corporations and i loved them they were
actually these cool people that truly
were just trying to solve this really
interesting scaling issue right
unfortunately what they were scaling is
not a good company right
but that doesn't mean that what they
were doing was invaluable it just means
go where your values align
and where what you bring to the table is
obviously valuable to them
okay
these exceptional performers if they
don't understand something then they get
the information they need to make its
importance clear
they just don't wait for someone to
bring it to them they don't complain
that somebody hasn't brought it they
just go get it they just go find the
answer
ask the right person i believe in no
hierarchy i know that it exists i
understand at a caveman level that we
have hierarchy i get that but
if it if your goal is to actually help
um your project get to a certain place
and your heart is the right place and
your head's my right place you saying
hey whoa i'm just going to skip right
the four levels up and talk to the
person who's making a decision about
this and ask them
if this is really what they want to go
where they want to go or show them a
different option
it it's always reported i've never seen
where it wasn't if you're just trying to
skip levels so that you can become
powerful and in control that's probably
the wrong thing if you're like hey a lot
of this red tape is in the way i just
need to know if this is truly the right
kind of architecture for this and i'm
not really getting anywhere with my team
so go to the person who's making that
decision
and they will see that you care that you
are demonstrating that you understand
that big picture right
in addition
these people are able to prioritize so
that their activities and energy are
focused of where they are of most value
to the company um has anybody ever heard
of the spoon analogy how many spoons you
have
a couple of you yeah okay
for those of you who have not
uh the idea is that energy for many
people including myself is that you are
you have a finite amount of spoons and
every time you have to do something or
somebody needs something from you you
give out a spoon but you only have so
many spoons right
and so sometimes you've given out a lot
and they just don't have any more energy
to do the thing
so the only way that you consistently do
good work is that you look at all the
things you have to do today and say if i
dropped everything except for one
which one of these spoons is the most
valuable to deliver today or to the
company or to yourself
and then if you don't get to all that
other stuff that sucks but you still got
that main important spoon done
got it
that has
completely changed how i handled being
overwhelmed at work with a lot of a lot
of different things to do like well if i
can at least do this thing or at least
do that thing i've done something today
that was valuable to them and is
valuable to me
but that brings me to another one which
is most of these super performers are
comfortable with being uncomfortable and
i
felt like that wasn't me um i felt like
i really wanted to feel like everything
was gonna be okay all the time
uh you have to be working on things that
are difficult for you
uh something i famously say is that if
it scares me i'm going to run towards it
because that means i probably don't
understand it and i need to understand
it right
even if you are distraction free and
getting a lot of coding hours in
if you're just building the same really
simple app over and over
that is not necessarily stretching the
boundaries of your skills but you will
totally get paid for it and that's okay
but we're talking about exceptional
performers right these stupid people
this is what they do
if you're not deliberately stretching
the boundaries of your skills you may
not be trying to structure skills in a
direction that will actually help you
grow as a technical contributor
if you do the same thing even though
it's comfortable to write an api in the
way i have
and you realize that lots of people are
moving in a different direction you may
get
lots of high paying jobs to deal with
legacy code and that's totally important
but if you are wondering why you're not
given more opportunities at new
companies could be because you are still
doing the same framework in the same way
that you've been doing it for 10 years
and that's totally okay as long as you
understand that is what you've chosen to
do you're not growing in your career
because you've chosen
to basically
dock in a port with your ship
okay that's totally fine
but
don't wonder why you're not getting paid
more money and why you're not getting
more responsibility okay
these exceptional performers like their
colleagues
i know
they must be lucky that's why they're
there part of that is true
high performers are in tune with the
people around them and they can sense
when they need something so
most of these people perform soft skills
like empathy
and
are able to relate well to other people
because they take the time and make the
effort to try to understand them
all of them all of the colleagues that
they work with on a regular basis even
the jerk yes
yes a high performer will put the human
first and seek that connection only then
can there be trust
i love this quote i think it's awesome
because every person needs to be seen
understood and validated or appreciated
in some way
you can dismiss someone who disagrees
with you
or you can try to figure out why they
say what they say
and do what they do this is a really
hard right now on twitter so i'm saying
that empathy is very much
it seems like a dying art
but it gives you grants you so much
value in your life
try to get some
get some empathy
that's how you become a trusted voice
because people will trust that you're
doing things for the right reasons
because you are listening and you are
applying what you're hearing
and you're reflecting
so that puts you in a camp of being much
more authentic and not just schmoozy
okay
i don't want you to become that
just break down
to the very lowest of the things that we
have in common as humans i remember i
had to i was told by my manager you need
to start getting along with this android
developer because i'm tired of hearing
you guys fight
i was like ah but he doesn't understand
the way that api is above and i was
tired of it and i felt like he was just
disrespecting me it was a whole mess
and so he says well maybe get some
empathy because maybe he has problems
with you
and i'm like
what i'm awesome what are you talking
about
and that was hard that was really
difficult because i do feel like he was
on purpose trying he like wanted to
fight all the time he wanted a reason to
shout his opinion from the heavens right
so instead of that being what we did is
i finally was like okay what did he what
does he do well
what does he do well i don't think
talking to people is one of them so what
did are the other things right that he'd
do well and i found some things
and i came at him later on saying hey i
know that you know this part really well
or better than me
why don't you make this you know tell us
where we need to do what we need to do
with this situation
and it totally softened everything he
said after because then he felt like he
was already validated and understood
he didn't have to prove himself every
two seconds to me it's difficult because
i was back an api engineer right and so
he felt like i understand how all
architecture works and you know
i i think we should do this and even
though i probably could have overridden
him because i have that experience
that was the wrong call
because if he's not bought into what
we're going to do
and that makes the whole thing painful
so i needed to dig
way down and find something that he did
well
and lead with it and it already like
immediately softened him to it so he was
much more willing to listen to me
sometimes you gotta just spy the bullet
and be the first one
i read a fantastic book called radical
candor by kim scott
fabulous so if you see in that book you
will recognize this quadrant
um
basically to me when i think of radical
candor it's like if you if you do this
for others be willing to encourage them
to do this back to you
yes so let's talk about the first one
the top left
ruinous empathy
there is a television show that i often
watched when i was much younger in the
states called friends and there was a
particular episode that i think calls us
out perfectly and it goes like this
there was a
character that
decided that they wanted to learn how to
play the piano and sing
and
of course
their friend was like oh that's great
you should keep doing that
very much and over and encourage her
like it was great he played clearly
off-key clearly not doing well um that's
okay she didn't want to discourage so
she over encouraged and she encouraged
and said oh my god it was amazing all
the time so much that he booked a gig to
perform in front of people because of
that and so what happened is that that
amazing amount of encouragement turned
into
kind of like an untruth
in the in his head like oh i must be
really good at this so i'm gonna stick
myself out there
it didn't go well and he wasn't asked
back for his gig and he came i'm like
i suck why didn't you tell me i sucked
i remember that's like oh because i
think you can do anything you want to do
and i just wanted to
encourage you
like but you told me it was really
awesome you didn't say hey you're
improving you said i was really amazing
oh
i am guilty of this one
because i have had so much unkindness in
my life i like want to over correct for
others
i will say this if you're not doing
something well
we probably need to call it out but you
have to kind of go through the stages of
this first so when you first meet
someone you don't know super well
or you're afraid of all conflict this is
where you go
is that you
over encouraged to the point of its kind
of ruinous for their career because
they'll bite off more than they can
truly chew at that time anyway
and then the whole ship goes down right
which leads to manipulative insincerity
um the best example i have of this is
when somebody
um is in charge of you doesn't really
know what you do i mean they know what
your job title is and they know you
deliver stuff but they could not do your
job
but they're you know you're poor to them
so let's say things aren't going well
you don't know that they're not going
well but they're not going well because
you don't ever have one-on-ones why
would you ever have those um but you get
called in office at one point in time or
saying hey let's just do a quick chat
very
i really dislike this approach it's very
corporate but it happens to small dev
teams as well
the best example i had was
hey you know we just want to like
write down all the things you've done
this year you know and have you sign off
on that just you know
to document it
right
because you know
every we're gonna do this oh my gosh
we're gonna do this with everybody
you know just write down all the things
that you understand what you've done
already and what the job is
uh just you know sign off on that and
really what they're doing is leading you
on so that they can document you to fire
you but they're not telling you that
that's what's gonna happen they just say
oh no we're doing this for everybody
it's manipulative insincerity
don't do this one
so don't
speak to someone in the way that you
think that they need to be spoken to in
order to hurt them in some way
attention please attention please a fire
has been reported within the building
please leave the building immediately
[Music]